I think Joe Biden's interest in her and
Jill Biden's interested it's connected
to the fact that there is a political
class who are obsessed with identity
and Ursula Wonderland Cuts This
brilliant figure in terms of identity
she's a mother of seven
she's a handsome woman who wears sort of
power suits and looks the part
but every job she's done she's done
disastrously that includes president of
European commission that includes
minister of defense for Germany a
spectacular failure she was in that role
the German troops were running out of
ammunition they were using broomsticks
instead of machine guns because they
were so badly equipped you haven't
exactly sold her Fred